it was 1883 when computer programming
started after centuries hundreds of
programming languages have come into
existence in the quest to be the most
agile and powerful enough to dominate
the industry a few impeccable ones
managed to withstand the test of time
and a few seem a lot ahead of time now
the question arises which of these
programming languages are the ones you
should learn so you are already watching
simply learn and today we bring you the
list of the top five programming
languages to learn in the year 2023. at
five we have Swift if you want to
develop anything for Apple Swift is your
savior originally Apple used Objective C
it was one of the oldest programming
languages that needed programmers to be
well aware of a large variety of
libraries Objective C was verbose and
time consuming to adapt so Apple
develops Swift and migrated from
Objective C dramatically minimizing the
efforts and time required to develop
software and applications for Apple
devices apart from Apple companies like
uber Robinhood and a few more financial
companies are active users of Swift
Apple software developers are highly
paid Professionals in India Swift
developers are paid 10 lakhs per year
and Swift developers bag about ninety
thousand dollars per annum in America up
ahead we have C and C plus plus the
humble languages of the entire clan of
programming C is titled the mother of
all programming languages the veteran
programming language has contributed a
lot to developing new languages
compilers databases and one of the most
popular operating systems Microsoft
Windows
on the other hand C plus plus is an
advanced version of C with
object-oriented programming abilities C
plus plus is used for web development
games and much more companies like
Microsoft Netflix and many more use
these programming languages the average
salary of C and C plus developers in
India is 10 lakhs per annum in the USA
the salary is one hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum next we have
the top three programming languages
you've been waiting for at three we have
JavaScript the most versatile and
Powerful language that turned the face
of the internet JavaScript is a leading
programming language with the highest
number of communities and active users
worldwide an astonishing number of 65
percent of programmers around the world
use JavaScript
sharing the podium are python with 48 in
the second and Java with 33 in the third
JavaScript is used majorly for web
development by companies like Netflix
Google PayPal big basket and more
the salary of a JavaScript developer in
India is one million six hundred
thousand per annum and in the USA the
salary is one hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars per annum at number two
we have Java
Java is Invincible among all languages
Java has the largest community
repositories and support it has spread
its roots into every software framework
mobile application big data and
operating system you name it Java did it
I.T giants like Ming and many other it
firms use Java the salary of a Java
developer in India is one million two
hundred thousand per annum and in the
USA the salary is a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars per annum finally our
number one programming language is
python
many believe that python is one of the
newest programming languages as a matter
of fact it's a veteran programming
language that is a lot older than Java
python was developed keeping one thing
in mind Simplicity python is not verbose
and it comes with the most simplistic
syntax python shares similar credibility
as Java in terms of operations and has
established its firm foot in the field
of data science and data analysis lately
Ming and it giants like Intel Pixar IBM
and more use python python ears earn
handsome salaries the salary of a python
programmer in India is 1 million per
annum and in the USA the salary is a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars per
annum that concludes our list of top
programming languages for the year 2023
whether you are a seasoned professional
or a fresh graduate looking to begin
your career in the industry an I.T
certification can open numerous doors
for you it can give you the technical
knowledge you need to advance your
professional journey and receive
lucrative compensation packages a
certification proves you have the right
skills and experience in a particular
field so you are watching simply learn
and today we bring you the list of top
five certifications for 2023 that will
boost your career at number five we have
big data nearly 2.5 quintillion bytes of
data are produced every day but the
expansion of the iot infrastructure is
only ramping up that pace organizations
harness their data and use big data
analytics to discover fresh
opportunities this results in smarter
business decisions increased profits and
happier clients simply learns Big Data
engineer certification covers all the
basics like Hadoop mongodb Pi spark Etc
alternatively the CCP data engineer
certification will train you to
transform and analyze data in cloudera's
CDH environment with 11.6 million jobs
predicted to open up by 2026 the future
scope is immense when it comes to Big
Data a big data engineer can earn up to
121 to 251 thousand dollars per annum in
the USA while earning 12.3 to 33 lakh
rupees per annum with the right
certification in India at number four we
have digital marketing
digital marketing is vital since it
links a company with its clients while
they are online and operates in so many
sectors the use of SEO and PPC social
media marketing email marketing and
Google helps businesses connect with
their prospective clients you can opt
for simply learns PGM program in digital
marketing which will help you master
skills like the fundamentals of digital
marketing SEO web analytics social media
marketing PPC
Etc
since people spend most of their time
online digital marketing is seen as a
Mainstay in the marketing industry
prompting higher paying scales and
increased demands for trained
professionals
a digital marketing manager can earn
between 60 to 160 thousand dollars per
annum working in the United States while
the same will net you 7 to 16 lakh
rupees per annum in India
at number three we have data science
data science is crucial in generating
new ideas and making sense of data since
it combines the subject matter expertise
of programming mathematics and
statistics data science combines
scientific techniques and algorithms to
extract only relevant and helpful
insights from a vast amount of data
simply learns data science Master
certification can help you get started
with python SQL data visualization and
machine learning
harvardx's data science professional
certification covers similar topics
using the r programming language with
data science automation trending
nowadays data science employment rates
are predicted to grow drastically in
2023 data scientists with the right
certification can earn up to 115 to 246
thousand dollars per annum in the United
States while those in India can earn up
to 8.2 to 20 lakh rupees per annum
at number two we have cloud computing
Big Data artificial intelligence and
machine learning are some of the newly
developing Technologies driving the
worldwide market for cloud computing
cloud computing which enables
organizations to store manage and
analyze crucial data uses remote
machines that are hosted online the AWS
certified Solutions architect associate
certification will enhance your ability
to architect deploy and secure
applications on AWS Cloud servers
similarly the Microsoft certified Azure
administrator helps professionals Master
deployment on Azure servers the global
cloud computing Market is set to grow by
20 between 2022 and 2029 a cloud
computing engineer earns 145 to 227
thousand dollars per annum in the US
while those working in India can earn 16
to 24 lakh rupees per annum
at number one we have ai and machine
learning your industry may require AI
experts very soon considering how
machine learning employment trends keep
growing in fields like deep learning and
natural language processing
AI is the design of computer systems
that can carry out tasks traditionally
requiring human intelligence
computers May learn and develop as they
have been exposed to database scenarios
thanks to a particular type of AI called
machine learning
simply learns postgraduate Ai and
machine learning program have been
designed in partnership with Purdue
University and IBM covering Concepts
like NLP statistics python machine
learning Etc alternatively Stanford's
machine learning certification is
available which covers an introduction
to machine learning statistical pattern
recognition data mining Etc
according to Gartner the AI software
Market is slated to become a 62 billion
dollar industry by 2023. the average
salary of an AI engineer is 140 to 386
thousand dollars per annum in the US and
between 6 and 20 lakh rupees in India
so there you have it the top five
certifications for 2023. if you need
help with any of the domains mentioned
in this video we have links for our
created courses by simply learn in the
description box thank you for watching
and stay safe
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here